Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is in
South Korea this morning on his
three-nation tour of Asia Tillerson is
defending President Trump's plan to cut
nearly 11 billion dollars from State
Department and other development
programs the budget blueprint gives less
money to the United Nations and
eliminates funding for UN climate change
programs James Baker recommended
Tellson's appointment as Secretary of
State Baker held that position in the
President George HW Bush he was also
President Ronald Reagan's Treasury
secretary and White House chief of staff
he joins us from the Baker Institute at
Rice University in Houston
good morning secretary Baker good
morning charlie delighted to see you or
hear you and and very very pleased to
know that you're back in stand still
pulling the sheet off your own face in
the morning Gail and I are so have him
here I'm happy to be back yeah yeah
these two people on both sides of me
will make you younger every day so let's
talk about the budget first the 26
percent cut in the state Department of
Budget all that some of that included
aid money foreign aid you believe in
diplomacy will this make diplomacy
harder well I don't think it will really
in the final analysis so Charlie I do
believe in diplomacy and I do I believe
that the State Department ought to have
sufficient funds to conduct robust
diplomacy for the country but I got to
tell you something as you indicated in
your introduction of me I also wore a
Treasury Hat for four years as Secretary
of Treasury and the biggest threat
facing this country today is that
ticking fiscal debt bomb of ours we have
we have a debt to GDP today of close to
a hundred percent that's not sustainable
for any country so we're going to have
to figure out ways to reduce that to cut
our budget you can't get the necessary
cuts of course from discretionary
spending like the like the
cutting the discretionary programs the
total government sooner or later if you
want to get the budget in balance you're
going to have to take on entitlements
that's difficult politically but Ronald
Reagan did it back in 1983 it can be
done without political damage and that's
something ultimately we're really gonna
have to do mr. secretary you are right I
mean 40% of the budget is Social
Security and Medicare and Trump doesn't
even touch that which is why these cuts
are so severe to the discretionary
spending dan Balz of the Washington Post
compared Trump's efforts to cut domestic
spending to that of Ronald Reagan in
1981 you were his chief of staff there
is that a fair comparison it's a very
fair comparison absolutely fair we got a
lot of grief if you remember back there
were you can't remember cuz you're not
old enough and just when Charlie Rose
remembers and it was you know we were we
were throwing with us and we were
throwing with us and often the orphans
out in the street it was a horror show
everything was going to go to hell in a
handbasket and it was going to be the
end of Western civilization as we know
it well we found that that's really not
correct and we do have to take on those
programs at some point the bottom line
though is you know you can't be strong
politically or diplomatically or
militarily if you're not strong
economically and that was what really
made this country in this special
country we are and we've got it we've
got to deal with this ticking fiscal
debt bomb there will be a lot of the you
know these this is the President's
budget it's never enacted by the
Congress there's gonna be a lot of
changes to it but it isn't the West or
the end of Western civilization yeah
let's talk about climate change if you
don't mind mr. secretary because you met
with White House officials last month to
talk to them about tax carbon emissions
as a way to fight climate change it
doesn't appear that they heard your
message what's your reaction to what
they've done how they've addressed that
in the budget
well we didn't we didn't expect that
they were going to jump on a jump all
over this but look this where this was
portrayed as a carbon tax that's really
not in sum and substance what it is it's
a carbon it's a carbon levy
demson program or or dividend program we
return every dollar that's collected to
the American people so it does not grow
government in that sense it is not a
taxed but initial vania said this Mick
Mulvaney said this we're not spending
money on that anymore we consider that
to be a waste well he's talking about
he's talking about programs that the
Obama administration initiated in which
we tried to convince other countries
that climate change is real and that
we'd but they need to address it that's
what he's talking about this program of
ours has never been implemented before
it's new it's brand-new it's
conservative
it's free-market it's limited government
and it's internationally competitive so
it's a different deal
teller Sutton is making a free country
tour he will he's been in Japan it would
be in Beijing and it's going to South
Korea right tell us what our options are
with respect to North Korea because he
has said our strategic patience is over
well it frankly should be over there are
no good options quite frankly the
military option is fraught with
considerable risk and danger north korea
has an incredibly large army poised just
30 miles from Seoul the capital of South
Korea we have a security alliance with
South Korea and Japan of course which
has frankly been the basis of stability
in the Pacific for a long long time
that's a tough option or if sanctioned
further sanctions sanctions can work
when they're multilateral China is the
key to that if we could get China to
come along with with and support more
robust sanctions I would be perhaps one
approach that might work China does not
want a nuclear Korean Peninsula there
they're against that too but they also
don't want the collapse of the North
Korean government and the influx of
refugees that that problem would present
to them all right secretary Baker you
have had the best line of the morning
Charlie Rose
taking the sheet off of his own face I
always wondered was there somebody there
with him now we know Charlie Rose moving
his own sheep thank you very much
secretary Baker it's always good to have
you always been at the table even by
South light thank you sir my pleasure